her friends call her chichi this 12 year
old is facing up to life without her mom
a mum who was everything she just bought
me off in like that love and kindness
and always taught me to be kind always
use my mind who's in everything and
she's just I don't know she just I guess
it was like I looked up to her a lot
like and always wanted to be like her
because she was just phenomenal in that
way I feel like how she always found a
way you through I feel like I can always
find a way through any challenge because
of that attitude she had Rotundo was 45
an administrator in the NHS in
Staffordshire they don't know how she
caught covert 19 but it proved too much
never be angry because there is no one
to blame would go to the hospital but it
was just I didn't really want to do it
anymore because it was like you just see
it from the window and yeah as much as
you want to go in and just hug it you
can't
only ten people could come to say a
proper goodbye
with her extended family mostly in
Zimbabwe a member of their church has
taken her in with the support of the
pastor in utox attain the thing that I
remember most about returned oh is a
smile and I now see that smiling in she
heads which is so exciting to see
because it wasn't like that in the first
few days but she's now starting to smile
she starting to be positive she's back
in school and her faith is really the
thing that's carrying her through it's
only been a month but her thoughts are
already for others as well as herself
many people lost their lives and we're
all grieving in different ways but
having a positive attitude towards it
and focusing on what you can do can
really help and could save her life in
time her future will be carefully worked
out but chichi has her mum's outlook on
life that anything can be overcome
Tom Parmenter Sky News Staffordshire